[Music]
so much has changed for them but some
things stay the same the Royal Christmas
day routine a family service at
Sandringham but with one much-loved
member missing
[Music]
and the King paying tribute to the lake
Queen in his first message as monarch
I am reminded of the deeply touching
letters cards and messages which so many
of you have sent my wife and myself
and I cannot thank you enough for the
love and sympathy you have shown our
whole family
Christmas is a particularly poignant
time for all of us who have lost loved
ones
we feel their absence at every familiar
turn of the season and remember them in
each cherished tradition
Ally filmed at St George's Chapel
Windsor the Queen's final resting place
it is the first ever televised message
from a king
foreign
and he uses it to delve more deeply
reflecting on the difficulties people
are facing at this time of great anxiety
and hardship
be it for those around the world facing
conflict famine or natural disaster or
for those at home finding ways to pay
their bills and keep their families fed
and warm his tone determined his message
more direct than his late mothers I
particularly want to pay tribute to all
those wonderfully kind people who so
generously give food or donations or
that most precious commodity of all that
time
to support those around them in greatest
need
Sandringham the king led his family out
of church with younger Royals stepping
up to support him including Prince Louis
making his debut here
a crowd pleaser for the fans who'd
queued for hours it's amazing fluid for
the first time it's just amazing It's
Made made my day really made my year now
oh my God it was amazing like we didn't
expect to be able to talk to him and
like my kids you know if I've got to see
him as well and you know this is a great
bit of history for us and trailing
behind a surprise appearance from prince
Andrew so rarely seen or heard in public
you seemed all right what are your
thoughts on him should he go back to the
royal family as a working Royal yeah I
think he should I think
um it's been served hasn't it it's been
done I think you can't you can't not
move on the Roth family had traveled all
the way from gateshead we meet the
special effort to come this year because
it's um King Charles's first one as
Monarch and obviously that's got special
significance this is the first family
Christmas at Sandringham for three years
a period that has seen seismic shifts
and it is a chance now Gathering here
for the king to try and show unity and
continuity it was a big turnout for both
family and fans another Milestone marked
as the royal family remembers the past
and plans a path for the future Laura
bundock Sky News Sandringham